bien en dos cuestiones en primer lugar
es muy difícil no desconectar a la
situación en yemen de la atención
existente entre irán y arabia saudita
entonces la respuesta a tu primera
pregunta de por qué las cosas han
cambiado tampoco el yemen en los últimos
seis años responde a que la atención
entre irán y arabia saudita en
particular durante la presidencia de
trump ha ido en ascenso no fijate como
la salida de trump y la llegada de biden
que ahora es del valle que está
justamente condicionando el apoyo que
eeuu le va a prestar a arabia saudita en
esta verdad ha hecho grandes ahorita
comience a intentar seducir a los hutíes
con un plan de paz
esta propuesta no era propuestas que
están llevando adelante los saudíes
parece ser muy sensatas y también muy
generosa de alguna manera porque han
ofrecido liberar
espacio aéreo en torno al aeropuerto de
saná y también los principales puertos
de la costa oeste que están actualmente
ocupados por los útiles por lo que de
alguna manera podemos percibir que hay
un ablandamiento 82 lo que acaba de
decir no es decir los hutíes se están
preparando para contraatacar pero bueno
estos gestos de incremento de la
violencia son también muy propios de las
negociaciones no es decir estamos en un
momento en el cual las negociaciones
están a punto de cristalizar me parece
no por lo que es lógico que las partes
comiencen a tensionar un poco más la
cuestión se para ver cuánto más pueden
entender del futuro acuerdo de paz ahora
se le preguntó cuál es el origen y la
razón de esta guerra sería por los
intereses de petróleo o hay otros
mezclados en todo esto
bien final esta guerra comienza no en
2011 de una manera muy tranquila como
una consecuencia de la velada de bebés
en septiembre de 2014 cuando los ies
rechazan al gobierno del presidente asad
y cuando se dan comienzo a esta guerra
los hutíes en ese momento van a comenzar
a dirimir una serie de valores
religiosos que aparentemente el
presidente alí no cumple pero bueno en
realidad era también la posibilidad de
irán de intervenir en la región y
generar otro foco de tensión
con arabia saudita que es su principal
rival regional no ahora porque un
ejército tan fuerte como el del área
saudita no ha sacado ventaja de todo
este conflicto
yo creo que arabia saudita ha sabido
sacar ventaja en los últimos meses
especialmente fundamentalmente después
del acuerdo que ha logrado con el día de
los árabes una de las cosas más curiosas
me parece de este conflicto es que los
emiratos árabes han demostrado o
demostraron entre 2017 y 2020 un marco
de autonomía no tomando decisiones
propias en el terreno sin contar con el
aval de arabia saudita y esto le
complicó las cosas más en esto le
complicó las cosas a justamente arabia
saudita creo que en septiembre de 2020
cuando finalmente enviando esa nave
decide unirse alinearse a la iniciativa
saudita es cuando podemos ver qué
el gobierno radial ha recuperado de
alguna manera la iniciativa que lo está
llevando a proponer este plan de paz que
es bastante generoso aunque parece ser
no tanto como para que los hutíes
todavía lo acepten y eso me da pie
entonces para preguntarles ahí del papel
que juegan las potencias internacionales
en este conflicto
y el papel que juegan las potencias
internacionales aquí es muy similar al
que juegan en la región no en toda la
región del medio oriente que de alguna
manera sirve como una caja de resonancia
a lo que sucede globalmente si eso se
debe también a las tensiones que hay en
el interior de cada uno de los estados
lo que hace que sean países mucho más
vulnerables a la influencia de lo que
sucede en el exterior y mucho más
débiles
al momento de tener que resistir no
estas oleadas de tendencias globales
entre diferentes actores